[Music]
in are you serious news submitted by
Littlefinger the manager of a beer
brewing company that is being sued for
discrimination claims he didn't know the
employee was black so to say the n-word
over and over again
well maybe the employer was wearing a
lot of hoodies Wow what if he was really
black and he doesn't see color I wanna
see this guy's picture
alright so I don't know he was back did
he ever see the employee or did he just
see him in apparel they were actually
friends like even before this employee
started working at this Brewing Company
I do have a friend or we have a friend
yeah that his dad is like black and then
I don't know I said he's like but as
that is black and his mom is white and
he looks very very white like that's
true he doesn't look black at all one of
our strippers in danger boys oh yeah
he's black yeah that's what's great yeah
so this guy looks like an Irish guy
maybe if you work in a ski lift and they
were there wearing ski jackets and shift
the whole time maybe you wouldn't know
that they're like oh what I know you're
a black you're a Jabberwocky the whole
time you're wearing that damn mask man I
never saw y'all change what was he
saying that he all right so this guy his
name is Tracey Evans this is what he
looks like
oh wow okay what did the guy think he
was Hawaiian I guess he could be some oh
and maybe she doesn't look black to me I
could see him as a Filipino guy - yeah
like
Islander like some sort of Hawaiian or
Samoa he was Russian he became one of
the first employees of color at founders
Brewing Company which is a pretty
popular craft brewery in Grand Rapids
Michigan and so he started there six
years ago but he was saying that over
time well initially he was passed over
for a promotion and so a year into his
employment and so this promotion ended
up going to two more recently hired
employees both of whom were white and so
Tracy ended up training both of them but
their behavior at the company was very
alarming he says because one had
drunkenly crashed his car into another
vehicle and another employee had
allegedly exposed himself to a crowd
where the [ __ ] do you find these
crazy-ass [ __ ] maybe out of brewery
so then when all of alcohol and then
when founders opened a tap room in
Detroit in 2017 Oh Tracy saw this as a
chance for a fresh start
so he ended up receiving a promotion to
manage promotions and events at that new
branch so good so far so good
yeah so then you're saying that at
Detroit though it things didn't get much
better because one co-worker noticed
that the brewery was starting to attract
more african-american customers and made
a comment about the establishments dark
clientele it's the Troy where do you
expect you [ __ ] later he called one
of Detroit's former black mayors Kwame
Kwame Kilpatrick however said they're on
the wrong I hope I said that wrong auto
correct we had a guest and this his I
came thanks for cut thanks for having me
even it wasn't great was it Josh just
leave it that's [ __ ] good there was a
long-ass time before I realized it was
an auto correct that is [ __ ]
hilarious he just sits there he's like
that's [ __ ] great like wow they're
really honest with this after we had him
in danger boys knows before anyway he's
still 10 yeah yeah he's like I hate
myself
I guess they hate me but I'm calm I'm
gonna do them a favor today yeah and do
yourself a favor don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
I hope I said that wrong I don't think
my brand does that sometimes when I want
to say right it says left and I'm like
no but I meant right all right bro I
heard your watch anyway sorry I hope I
said that correctly I don't want to say
it wrong anyway so back to this story he
this same employee or coworker later
called Detroit's former black mayor the
head n-word in charge down he was saying
the trace was saying that there were all
these racist things that kept going on
question went to HR immediately good
boss I mean for him it's like the [ __ ]
it's like really racist and she's like
there and he's like head and word in
charge any surprised you're black we
actually found a guy who doesn't see
race I know but there's a conversation I
really want me and Nikki to read okay so
ridiculous in the deposition I'm trying
to get there yes so anyways so then um
you're saying that from there was this
one day that he was just so frustrated
by the situation because he was going to
HR and so he took a personal day to
drive back to Grand Rapids and meet with
the human resources officer in person
but when he returned to work the
following week in late 2017 he was fired
almost immediately with bosses citing
missed deadlines on a project so he sued
alleging he was discriminated against on
the basis of his race and so that's when
it led to one of the founders managers
saying that he denied to is or he was
denying to confirm that he was black
Anson this is when now we're gonna read
this conversation and it's kind of long
so bear with us let's try to get it
through you can be the attorney and I'll
be the former manager Ryan Schultz okay
I'm an attorney when did you first meet
Tracey Evans 2011 2012 we had a mutual
we had mutual friends before working
there so
okay so you knew Tracy prior to his
employment at founders we met a few
times yes okay are you aware Tracy is
black what do you mean by that are you
aware that Tracy is african-american I'm
not sure of his lineage so I can't
answer that
all right are you aware that Tracy is a
man of color what do you mean by that
Oh bro no do you know you don't know
what it means for someone to be a white
person or a black person I'm asking for
a clarification you don't need any I can
promise you that we'll keep the record
as is someone's skin color a white so
that's what you're referring to yeah oh
yeah yeah okay yes I know the difference
in skin tone are you able to identify
individuals by their skin tone what do
you mean identify I mean have you ever
looked at Tracy Evans in your entire
life have you that's a genuine question
the founders attorney says objection
argumentative you can answer and then
Ryan says yes and did you ever realize
that Tracy skin is black that's not I
mean is this skin different from mine
yes how what do you mean how it's a
different color and what is a difference
of color it's darker and that means
attorney objection vague question I mean
we could this could be a one sentence
answer you know so by your I guess your
testimony is you have no idea of Tracy
as a minority if he's african-american
I don't know Tracy's lineage so I can't
speculate on whether he's if he's from
Africa or not
what do you mean lineage from Africa no
I mean like I don't know his DNA have
you ever met black people who aren't
from Africa have you ever met a black
person born in America yes and you were
able have you ever met a black person
who didn't tell you they were black can
you rephrase that
is Barack Obama black objection to your
knowledge I've never met Barack Obama so
I don't know you
Obama is black what about Michael Jordan
do you know if Michael Jordan is black
objection I've never met him
so you don't know him what about I have
to meet people to know if they're black
or not
what about Kwame Kilpatrick never met
him to your knowledge was Kwame
Kilpatrick black eye you don't know I
don't know what was his goal in trying
to dodge the answer out of these trying
to dodge it I think that's how stupid he
is he thinks by admitting that his
whatever his race is that might be the
game plan which if you admit to the race
then you have to admit to the fact that
there was discrimination yeah so the
founders are like the company the Byrne
company said mr. Ryan was simply saying
that he does not assume anything about
individuals race or ethnicity unless
they tell him that information while it
might be acceptable to speculate about
this type of thing in casual
conversation mr. Ryan was not having a
casual conversation he was under oath
when he made these statements dude we
should have this guy meet Obama and then
have a whole press guy go outside and
microphones and stuff and he comes out
of the house and he goes up to the
microphones and he's like I haven't met
Barack Obama I hide his I think he's
white actually
well he's technically 50% true true I
mean how do you even define it right I
know so then they're saying here like uh
there's this blind ignorance that's the
larger story here because a lot of these
white owned companies and it's not just
Detroit it's all over the country come
in have this sort of blindness to overt
racism and it has to be called out so
they're saying like how can one expect
to know what minorities go through if
they can't even acknowledge that some
employees are minorities I don't even
know how white people be running their
business because I just think good
business owners will reward and keep the
best employees and if they're sitting
there going you're black you're this so
I'm not gonna give you promotions I'm
gonna recognize these white people who
are a lot more incompetent and showing
their dick off to customers it's just
bad business
period
so I don't know how if you run your
mouth that's good but that's because
they're showing their dick does it make
it I don't know maybe because I'm not
around this world so I have no [ __ ]
clue but to me that's just bad business
to reward people that suck and you you
just wanna you want to keep high
performers but and you're a racist the
thing but I like this if you're a racist
and and then you don't really have to
have your employees that much like you
should go to your upper management
meetings or whatever and if you start to
fill the room that room with people that
you don't like you're not gonna do that
right so you're gonna you're gonna not
hire those those people so you don't
have to hang with them as much good I
don't know because most business people
I think are more pragmatic and profit
driven so they don't at least I've never
really met an entrepreneur who gives a
[ __ ] about male female transgender race
day go can this person sell can this
person [ __ ] build my company can this
person kill it in my department as the
New Age entrepreneur the old age like if
you think about the guy that like has
the cowboy hat and boots and he's always
go to Texas or Kentucky like Bourbons
always been made this way how about Wall
Street
how about [ __ ] College yeah like
those guys same [ __ ] they would they
don't want to live around minorities
yeah they they live in mostly ultra
white neighborhoods at all times like
there's always this like 10-gallon
cowboy hat [ __ ] image that we do but
we don't notice like all the people who
live in [ __ ] Boston who only hire
like other white people who don't hire
upper management yeah Nora T's ever but
then they call themselves liberals yeah
some of those business owners they don't
even want the product to be consumed by
minorities right that's what I don't
understand that's what I understand cuz
I never met these people I know that
they might exist and all that and I've
heard from other you know reputable
sources that's experienced this stuff
but my thing is always if I'm
uncomfortable in that situation I'm
gonna leave and on top of that we
have the opportunity here to compete
with them so if you're feeling like like
this guy right you want to work in a
brewery what I would do is I call this
Chinese e mem right what you do is you
learn the [ __ ] out of their business you
take all of their [ __ ] suppliers and
everybody you leave and you build a
minority-owned company you hire people
you like and if they're gonna be stupid
and only hire like people that they want
around but they're not the best skilled
use you compete with them hire people
that are [ __ ] better more skilled take
their [ __ ] company out that's
literally America so so instead of no
it's playing that role like we have the
choice as minorities to build our own
companies and compete with white
companies right we don't have to be in
there we don't have to work for them is
what I'm saying yeah what he's trying to
do is get that first paycheck I hope so
but I mean that's just my philosophy I
think we should compete and we should
battle them face-to-face not ours right
away you know half the people watching a
new [ __ ] about race issues go back to
their white neighborhoods at night well
they would say that hire they hire
minorities no no as gardeners as Jan
exactly nice you mean the the white
people that argue for racism the
limousine liberals on the limousine
liberals
[Music]
[Music]